hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast
number 78 live stream with dr heather
hyng
and me brett weinstein i am now
repeating myself because apparently
there was a sound problem but uh
i think it is now cured here we go yes
it's may 1st
spring is in full swing here in the
gorgeous pacific northwest we are going
to talk about today
the uh recent kerfuffle between joe
rogan and fouchy
and uh what it what it might
mean also talk some about vaccines
uh separately from that right um
you want to talk about a little bit
that's going on in portland still
yes right which is our our hometown
um i have a little little item in which
uh our our vice president goes off
script off script i think
yes yes and um and the ap
the associated press is making some odd
claims about race
and all of that will take up a lot of
time but i
really want to talk about nature too so
we're going to talk about the columbia
for gorge
and gopher snakes and ravens and
rattlesnakes and
salamanders and shorebird migration and
uh we'll have pictures for a few of
those and um
just actually actually back to what i
still consider my roots talking about
talking about the animals is it uh is it
wrong of me to conclude that this is
an eclectic grouping of concepts yeah i
think it kind of often is
from vice presidential off scriptedness
to
snakes ravens being onscript oh always i
think the raven that we saw yes
um doing something kind of extraordinary
uh was actually entirely unscripted yes
i was looking at the photograph and i
was hoping that we have it right and
then it's a raven but anyway you're
going to tell me
so we'll find out i mean i was there yes
you were there but i mean
you know the distance the camera does
magnify these things and lets you see it
better
uh you know i we may be wrong um but uh
but we will hear that from you
absolutely you know what that does tell
me i do have a correction i forgot about
okay which was that last week i showed a
picture that i thought was a golden
eagle yes it
in fact does look very much uh like a
golden eagle but
a um something this is two weeks ago but
hmm i think it was last week in any case
it turns out
that that was a juvenile bald eagle
which was something i had considered the
possibility of and i had rejected it on
the basis that it was too big
it would seem to be larger than uh an
adult bald eagle on the other hand
very hard to know because the scale of a
bird in flight is uh
you know impossible to assess so it
seems like i got it wrong and the
diagnostic characteristic was the middle
shape
yes and that in fact that was last week
i was wrong so here we're just uh going
recursive on our
our corrections here because it was in
fact the thumbnail that we used for last
week
yeah um all right so um
before we launch into all of that though
um just a reminder to
please subscribe like uh go to our clips
channel do the same
thing don't just like love it's not an
option oh
all right sorry it's not awesome she got
carried away um we are actually i mean
we we feel that
actually um from people who write in and
are
are grateful for as i've said before
almost everyone who writes in
and the messages that you are sending us
um and also uh consider joining us on
either of our patreons brett
um was supposed to have a conversation
this morning there was a tech snafu so
actually
based on the fact that zoom no one cares
yes they don't care yeah so there's one
tomorrow and there's one actually next
saturday that you could join yep yeah
that's right
yeah um all right you why don't you
launch us
into uh talking about what happened this
week
between uh joe rogan and the esteemed dr
patrick
sure and while i'm at it you should
ready that link that i sent you
uh that you brought up um
[Music]
so many links so what happened this week
was that joe rogan in conversation with
comedian
dave smith said something offhandedly
about advice that he would give to
a young person considering whether or
not to get vaccinated
for covid actually maybe zach we should
show that clip do you have it
[Music]
yeah i think for the most part it's safe
to get vaccinated i do i
do but if you're like 21 years old and
you say to me should i get vaccinated i
go no
yeah are you healthy are you a healthy
person
like look don't do anything stupid but
you should take care of yourself
you should if you're if you're a healthy
person and you're exercising all the
time and you're young
and you're eating well like i don't
think you need to worry about this
now rogan was careful not to say that
all people shouldn't be vaccinated okay
so um that was joe rogan and what he
said
is that if he was advising a healthy
person something like 21 years of age
um that he would likely advise them not
to get the vaccine
and the world jumped on joe and of
course
mocked him and made fun of him for not
having the expertise
to say such things and my sense was
although i didn't think joe gave a
complete analysis here of why
what he suggested might make sense i
actually didn't think that the advice he
was giving was so
terrible because of course there are all
sorts of questions that do
suggest we should at least be thinking
twice about advising young people
to get the vaccine so in other words uh
well
what we had was we had uh fouchy
weighing in and saying that of course
young people should get the vaccine and
then
fauci although i don't think joe was
wrong fauci said some things that were
true
what he said was that joe's analysis
seemed to pay attention only to one's
personal
well-being and that he was not paying
proper attention to the fact
that a healthy person who gets coveted
and suffers from it only very little
may be exposing other people to the
virus and they may suffer greatly and in
fact could
could die from it and that that is a
reason to get the vaccine and
in isolation uh that uh analysis
is probably right but that analysis does
not
um in isolation and so i wanted to
take some time to sort through the
various things that contribute to the
analysis of
who should get vaccinated but you had a
point yeah i mean there are many points
to be made here and i know we're going
to spend some time talking about this
but
um just to finish up your sort of
reporting of what it is that you're
responding to here
uh joe did uh clarify with an additional
statement after faux
said what he said and it's too long i
think to play here it's you know five
seven minute um thing but uh he made he
he
exactly um repeated the point that you
just made which is this is an individual
enamel
individual level analysis not a
population level analysis and he was not
presuming to make the population level
analysis
those aren't his words right now i saw
the retraction
or the walking back it wasn't really a
retraction but in any case i was a
little bit
concerned about it because my sense is
you know
joe is a layperson he was having a
discussion that did not pretend to be
uh authoritative in this regard and so
it was incomplete but it wasn't
pretending to be a complete
analysis and um the fact is i thought
joe was on much stronger ground
in light of what we've been talking
about on dark horse for
so many months now which is the huge
unknowns that surround vaccine safety
long term and so the analysis about
whether or not a young person
should get vaccinated should center
on some kind of balance between yes the
possibility that a young person could
get
coveted could pass it on to other people
but also the possibility that a young
person could get a vaccine and then
suffer
hazards down the road and that analysis
does not suggest that this is clear-cut
in fouchy's direction
um that is my water kitty cat that this
is clear-cut in in fouti's direction and
against joe
so i thought uh you know i mean i
certainly understood that
joe was in a bad position um that in
effect somebody
you know without a credential was
vulnerable to the world piling on that
he was giving medical advice that he
wasn't in a position to give
but he wasn't pretending to be a medical
authority um so
before we start walking through some of
some of what we do
see with regard to the data um
the wapo the washington post joined the
fray with uh
this uh piece you can show my screen
just for me to read the headline zack
joe rogan is using his wildly popular
podcast to question vaccines
experts are fighting back uh so that's
you know one of one of the main
news outlets uh in the united states
here and i'm just going to read from my
screen zach so you don't have to show
um show it again um two paragraphs near
the end
of this wapo article dated april 29th
this is two days ago
misinformation coming from someone like
rogan continues to perpetuate doubt said
kalina koltai a vaccine misinformation
researcher at the university of
washington
a lot of young adults follow him and
he's encouraging people to have
hesitation
koltai pointed out that quote no one is
getting all of their information from
joe rogan
but when his comments clash with what
experts tell us it helps muddy the
waters
quote hearing these conflicting messages
from someone you might trust and someone
you might agree with typically
it can potentially cause you to be
concerned she said quote
oftentimes it just ends up confusing
people and making them not sure what to
do
so that language struck me as so
anti-scientific
and um like just antithetical to
skepticism
um that although i don't tend to do this
certainly not on air i just i went and
figured out who this person was who was
being trotted out as the
expert who is saying that uh that rogan
doesn't know what he's doing
um she's a postdoc at uw at university
of washington
with a phd in quote information studies
she's not a scientist
and she states on the website um the
university website that she researches
quote decision making with a focus on
when people dissent from the scientific
mainstream
that has nothing to do with science and
that actually may exactly be
training that she has that that allows
her to speak as if expert here
that runs exactly opposed to what the
scientific method is she may well know
what information is
and and what it looks like when people
start to disbelieve
things that most people believe to be
true but disbelieving what most people
believe to be true does not mean
that those people are themselves wrong i
don't think that she i i see nothing and
i spent just a little bit of time with
her website
um indicating that she actually
understands what the scientific method
is
and i'm not saying that you know if i
put her and joe rogan in a room
um and ask them to find the scientific
method that one of them would obviously
come out on top but i feel like
joe is personifying on a regular basis
a skeptical approach to the world in
which he is using largely his intuition
rather than formal training to try to
navigate
and he is not accepting the basis of
authority
and you know we are being told in
response how dare you listen to this man
you must trust the authorities and the
authorities
are over and over and over again
demonstrating that they actually don't
even know what science is
right in fact the entire idea of
taking science and marshaling against
those who would challenge it is the
height of
unscientific right everything we now
believe
started out as a heterodoxy right and it
comes to be orthodoxy because it
withstands tests and we find out how it
works
but the point is do you really think
that we're in a place where you can
freeze that process now
it's like it's god-given right this is a
religious perspective
the scientific perspective is you know
we don't know what of the things that we
believe today we will come to discover
are false tomorrow right but we
understand that that is
the pattern anybody who studied the
history of science
knows that and so yes the idea that
departing from heterodoxy is
evidence of something having gone awry
or somebody overstepping
uh the bounds or something is is
nonsense on its face
now to steal man say fouchy's and the
so-called expert's position
here um this does come down to
is this an individual versus a
population level analysis
um because the you know the assessment
that say joe was doing
um and that we have largely been um
doing when we have talked about these
things
here are is this the right decision for
you
is this safe for individuals and the
epidemiological question
is a different kind of analysis the what
what amount of protection does a
population need so that we can safely go
back to normal
and you know what does safe mean and
what is your tolerance for risk and all
of these things need to be wrapped up
into that but
that is a different kind of analysis
well it is a wholly different kind of
analysis but my claim
is that we are actually not in a
position where anybody gets to wave that
at you and the reason they don't get to
wave that at you is because
they have botched their side of a
contract right yeah
and believe me i i'm i'm always in this
weird position where i have to explain
what my own values would mean if we were
if we were navigating this
the way i think we should be navigating
this we would be having a thoroughly
open discussion in which heterodoxy was
absolutely welcome and people were able
to level whatever challenges
and be protected in so doing and so we
would have a really good understanding
of what the risks of these vaccines are
what the risks from covid are what the
uncertainties about both
are and then once we had done that
analysis once people had
hashed out the question of how do we
compare the risks that come from covid
with the risks that come from
vaccines based on unknown technologies
accelerated through this process
once we had done that i do feel like
society has
the right to coerce people to take their
share of the risk to shut down
a pandemic that threatens us all but we
aren't remotely in that world and i
don't want to be told by
any of these people who are busy
participating and obscuring those risks
that i or my children or people
who know better have to take these risks
because that's simply
part of you know our duty to society
society has fallen down on its side
of this equation and of course the irony
of ironies
is that fauci is the one telling us what
our duty to society is
right because fauci played a role in
uh restarting gain of function research
which it is ever clear may have played a
decisive role in creating the pandemic
so
you know frankly you know this i'm sure
that that was an
honest mistake on his part but the fact
is
some people like fauci used to believe
gain of function research was safe
enough that we could engage in it and
not put the world at risk of a major
pandemic it's becoming clear
that that wasn't the case right whether
or not this pandemic is the result
of a laboratory escape it is clear that
things escape laboratories routinely and
gain a function research is perfectly
capable of creating a nightmare virus
and so did it happen here we have yet to
find out
but wow is fouchy not in a position to
wag his finger at the rest of us
yeah um also there's the mask fiasco
where he
uh you know lied about whether or not
masks were valuable
and then later acknowledged that's what
he had done so
he's not he's not in a position to do it
but if i can just reset the discussion
just slightly i want to point out
that there is a hierarchy of categories
and that all of these discussions should
recognize
that we are being asked to move from one
category to another so actually
zach could you put up the uh risk
categories for the living that i sent
you
so not seen this um my claim can you
give me one of your copies
sure in fact that is your copy i printed
it for you
um so my claim
is that there are four large categories
that you could be in
the first one is you haven't had covid
or a vaccine that's the category
you and i are in and that one carries no
risk in and of itself
um and an unknown ongoing susceptibility
to covet risk
that is to say you are the risk is zero
of not having a vaccine and not having
covet and the risk of getting covet is
unknown so this is very unclear to me i
i think i know what you mean
but obviously if you haven't if you're
not protected from covid covet as we
have said many many times
is a dangerous disease oh yes there's no
risk i mean there's not no risk
no well i think this would be come clear
as well okay go through it
the point is you're not having a risk
from either covid or the vaccine if you
haven't had either
you do have a risk of getting covid
which will be destructive and it is a
very dangerous disease but you don't
have any risk going forward from your
status because you're basically
you haven't been affected by either yet
second category
is you have had the vaccine but you have
not had covid
right now presumably that has a small
short-term risk although
i don't think we have a good sense of
how small that short-term risk is and
there are certainly
a tremendous number of anecdote even
just among the people that we know who
have gotten
the vaccine of all kinds of pathologies
that have shown up
and the long-term risk in category 2
that is to say you have had the vaccine
but you have not had covid
is entirely unknown we don't know what
the long-term risk of these
vaccines is the third category is you've
had covid
but no vaccine there is substantial
short-term risk from having had covered
tissue damage as we have covered many
times
and the long-term risk from having had
covet is unknown but likely substantial
that is to say tissue damage has an
ongoing cost
and then there is category four where
you've had both and i've had to divide
this into two because the order in which
you've had
covid and the vaccine probably makes a
big difference
if you had covid first
then there might even be a benefit to
those who have had what's called
long-haul covid
right there is some evidence that
there's some anecdotal stories of people
um
getting recovering from long-haul coping
after getting a vaccine right which i
i should say in passing i think implies
that long-haul covet is an autoimmune
disorder
right because if if you have
autoimmunity your immune system is now
attacking your tissues having cleared
covid but it still thinks there's
something there
and it's attacking you and then you
flood the system with spike protein
generated by the vaccine that may occupy
the cells that are otherwise attacking
your tissue
and give you relief
okay and then
category the category four you've had
both but you had the vaccine
first then you will have
greatly reduced coveted risk that is to
say
we believe from the data we have seen
that covet is less severe if you get it
having had the vaccine
um and that means you're less likely to
get it and it's less likely to be severe
if you do get it
right um and uh that
uh yeah it's less likely to be severe so
you probably have a reduced long-term
risk though we don't know that for sure
either yep okay my basic point here so i
will say
i just i think it's i i think it's
guaranteed that that
screenshot is going to be taken out of
context of the conversation and the idea
that having had covert
vaccine is no risk is nothing that you
actually believe
and that is um i i i wish you hadn't
written that on this piece of paper
because
that's not what you mean yeah i
absolutely do not as we have said many
times and as i have said to joe rogan i
believe
on his program um the fact that
covet is less deadly than we once
thought is
misleading people it's a very dangerous
disease on the basis
of tissue damage and it's robbing people
of
uh years of life in all probability if
everything we understand about
physiology and tissue repair is true
then the significant damage it does is
very harmful and you definitely want to
avoid covid
that said we are in a situation
where without the ability to know what
the long-term consequences are
you do have to ask a question about for
whom
is it worth taking the risk of the
vaccine and that's the thing that
that joe was addressing so um before we
go to the economist thing which you
you've just sprung on me at the very
last minute i have not seen yet so
um can we just show the cdc table since
that is something that is easy to
interpret and it's not um
interactive so zach you can show my
screen
which both brett and i are familiar with
already this is a
chart at the cdc updated february 18th
of this year
risk for coping 19 infection
hospitalization and
death by age group so they are they've
split um age groups
into um several of different
um different spans which is weird all
right 0 to 4 years old 5 to 17 years old
18 to 29
30 to 39 40 to 49 50 to 64. why they
expand the
the number of years as we're getting
older and as the risk is getting higher
i don't
understand like this this is a strange
strange table
and then there's three categories cases
risk of risk of getting it in each of
those age groups
risk of hospitalization each of those
age groups and risk of death in each of
those age groups and as we've said many
many
times focusing only on death is not the
right way to think about the true risk
of this
disease and for the purposes of this
table
they have used the 5 to 17 year old
category which is too broad
but the 5 to 17 year old category as the
reference group so that's sort of that's
that's default that's um that's one
and what you can see uh for those um
listening only and not watching is that
interestingly
cases um increase
uh the older you get above 17 years old
um in until you get to 65 to 84 year
olds and then it's down again
um so i don't know what that's about um
well it could be that the cohort is
small i don't know how what the
methodology was
well it's ratios it's not it's not
absolute numbers um
but but the two other the two other
metrics that they're using here are
hospitalizations and deaths
which follow exactly what we all know
everyone who hasn't been under a log for
the last 14 months
knows which is that um the older you get
um the greater your risk of
hospitalization and the greater your
risk of death with for instance
in um just for hospitalizations um
18 to 29 year olds are six times at risk
as five to 17 year olds
uh the next age group is 10 times then
15 then 25
40 65 95 times the risk for 85 plus
year old people and it's for death it's
8 700 times the risk
but before you say something here um
what is also interesting is that the
very young
zero to four year olds actually have a
higher risk of hospitalization
and death from kovid only twice but then
do
the five to 17 year olds okay but i have
to say this chart
has me jumping out of my skin i cannot
think of a justification for having put
it together this way
it is absolutely misleading and in a
direction that we are now being scolded
with
and i believe it uh you know i
i cannot establish it could just be
ineptitude that caused this
but the idea of these broad categories
in a case where you have not even a
linear relationship
in which the hazard goes up with time
but an exponential relationship
the idea of grouping 5 to 17 year olds
making them the reference category and
then deriving an
8700 times uh
risk from that reference category that's
basically using the fact in
in this is a scary table but in fact
what it says is that the number is very
very tiny in that 5
to 17-year group and the fact is
5 to 17 years is a weird jump to have
made so
the i don't i don't know what's
misleading back when we were in graduate
school
i uh did a joke survey you may or may
not recall we were in the field
and um my joke survey in costa rica
costa rica um what i did was i did a
survey to see what the density of
non-avian dinosaurs
was per hectare in a study area
and the way i did my study was i had
categories i would count the number of
non-avian dinosaurs
and i had a category if a hectare had
zero to five
i ranked it as 2.5 etc
right and then um it turned out
that there were um an average of 2.5
dinosaurs per hectare
that's that's hilarious but
i don't see how like this this
table chart i don't even know what to
call it um this this table
yes lumps 5 to 17 year old people and we
know that we can get greater granularity
than that
and the 5 to 10 year olds are at
significantly lower risk than the 10 to
15 year olds for instance
but um but there's nothing that goes
counter to those numbers here we've just
in
in this case we've just got a collapse
of two categories that are very very
similar a sophisticated person can
figure out what this chart does and
doesn't mean and what it does mean is
that they've effectively done surgery
with an
axe right those large categories don't
have to be there it doesn't add clarity
and in fact you can see if you go to the
economist
as an alternative way of viewing this
kind of information so
i'm not vouching for this
because i have not seen it you just
literally sent it to me
so scroll up zack you can show it honey
okay
that chart okay this chart gives you
enough granularity to see
what the uh the risks are right so
people are some people are just
listening what what are we looking at
what we are looking at
is scroll back out scroll back out
estimated covid19 risk if diagnosed in
the united states
and what we have is a curve it's
not perfectly smooth but we have a curve
and you can see risks are extremely low
you can switch between males and females
right so at 21 go to 21 you have about a
1
risk of hospitalizations this is the
exact number that joe rogan was talking
about for men
and it's way lower it's even lower and
then you can move by
age and you also can add uh
medical conditions as you want if
interestingly i think i added asthma
just to see how it worked and the
numbers drop i've also heard that it
just so that paradoxical
results this seems this seems cool it
does not allow us
um you know this this has
hospitalizations and deaths and it
doesn't
um say how likely you are to get the
thing in the first place right you know
the case rate
which is what the co which is what the
cdc graph
table did show right but that cdc table
creates i believe a false impression on
the base of making giant categories for
no reason
my point here is that the granularity of
this
allows you to see how steeply your risks
go up and so
if we're going to wag our fingers at joe
rogan we need to understand that what he
said
requires us to take the condition
of a healthy 21 year old right to give
them an
unknown risk from an from a unproven
technology
at that age not only are they taking a
risk of an
unproven technology but their lives are
going to be longer and so the time
in which something can go wrong is that
much greater as we've discussed here on
dark horse
multiple times and so the point is
if all joe said was that if he was
advising a person at 21 whether or not
to take the vaccine
if they were healthy and they weren't
going to take stupid risks
he would advise against it and whether
or not that is the right advice
it is certainly fair for a person or
that person's parent i mean i guess a 21
year old is old enough to decide for
himself but
that person has to be able to judge what
is the risk that i'm going to do my
self-harm with a vaccine
that i would not suffer if i uh
if i stayed away from the vaccine and so
um
that is a reasonable question for us to
ask and again if
some uh panel that was completely immune
from perverse incentives
and well positioned to see all of the
data
and to look at the patterns was to say
actually we don't know what your
long-term risk is but here are the
reasons we think it's low here are the
risks we think you suffer
you know of both getting covet and if
you get covered what the consequences
are
and here's why this is uh either
better for you or if it's somewhat worse
for you
it is a manageable level of worse and
the advantage that comes to society of
nobody being downstream of you who gets
the disease which mind you
isn't even the case it's not like these
vaccines are perfectly effective at
keeping people
from getting and passing on covid though
they do appear somewhat effective
so it is a reasonable question to ask of
course it is
um it is you know as you just alluded to
it is constantly a struggle
to get the conversation to toggle
explicitly between
individual level decisions and what is
best for society
and um you know broadly speaking
um the people on the political right
tend to focus on individual level rights
and the people on the political left
tend to focus on population level
level rights and um you know we have
been arguing as people who
um have long been on the left that of
course we need to be doing both
um that we have responsibilities to each
other um having gotten
rights um from society we have
responsibilities in return
and we also exist as individuals and
what what the scientific method is very
good at and what you and i are very good
at
is assessing um in this case
individual level risks and the
population level analysis
is tougher and i have yet to see
a careful a careful explanation of what
is going on
to make the recommendations what they
are as opposed to simply let's
let's bludgeon the populace with the
sense that if they don't do this there's
something wrong with them
and um they simply must there are plenty
of us
out here who would like the information
and
are not interested in simply taking it
on someone's authority especially
someone who has reliably demonstrated
that their authority is not particularly
reliable
well but i think i think my point goes
one step beyond that which is
what we can see of the analysis so far
tells us that nobody has the information
to balance these concerns right if they
have it it's private we haven't heard it
right well that's that's my point that i
you know i want
i i want to have access to that
information right it would be great to
have access to that information but
knowing that we don't
right knowing that what we have is the
pretense of vaccines that are safe
um when there is at least a large
unknown risk of a long-term hazard and
that that is not being discussed
we are forced to default into actually
protecting our personal well-being
if we haven't been given the information
to say actually why
why is it that i as an individual i'm
taking some risk i'm doing it
because um collectively we need me to do
it but if i can't calibrate
the value and can't calibrate the risk
to myself
then i'm justified and in fact i would
say we've got two
two liberal things against each other on
the one hand
we've got um the i think uh
justifiable focus on collective
well-being and having to balance it with
individual well-being
but we also have the precautionary
principle and the fact is we are
effectively being
shamed out of applying the precautionary
principle to our own well-being
in order uh to make this all work out
and
at the same time actually zach would you
put up the uh
the thumbnail for um crystal ball
uh from the hell so this
is just one more piece of information in
the stream but
uh crystal ball had a very good piece
this week
on bill gates and his
insistence that um patent protections be
maintained that effectively
a pharmaceutical company patent
protections be maintained
in order to keep the flow of resources
going
even though that surely means fewer
people are going to end up vaccinated
and in fact
her accusation is that bill is lying
that he claims there are no facilities
that could be
brought into creating vaccine if the
patents were relaxed so there's no
benefit to doing it
and in fact that is um absolutely false
there are apparently
so what we've got on the one hand is
business as usual taking place in pharma
land
you know we have public financing of the
research that creates these things
and then we have the privatization of
the prophets and we don't have a
footing as you might get during a war
where
factories are brought into the national
interest and are making weapons or
something like that what we have is the
pharmaceutical industry
continuing to practice its uh its
business as as usual
in spite of the fact that it will cost
lives if these vaccines are the
lifesavers that
are being claimed so we are being told
we have to take risks that cannot be
calibrated
when others are not showing that this is
you know that all hands on deck moment
and that they are doing the same with
their business profits it just doesn't
add up
so apropos um unknown risks
uh this just came out from the salk
institute yesterday
you can show my screen just for me to
again read the headline here
zach the novel coronavirus's spike
protein plays additional key role in
illness
selk researchers and collaborators show
how the protein damages cells
confirming covet 19 is a primarily
vascular disease
so that was posted on the salk
institute's website yesterday and they
refer
obviously as you would expect them to to
the paper that was published
but the paper doesn't seem to be
accessible and through any of my normal
um normal roots and i don't know why
that is i'm not going to
hypothesize about that here but because
the um the sort of lay audience
explication of what this is is coming
from the salk institute as well i find
it a reliable source in this case
um and you know so what they say is and
this is just a quote from that
uh that page that i was just showing in
the new study
the researchers created a pseudo virus
that was surrounded by sars kovi to
classic crown of spike proteins
but did not contain any actual virus
exposure to the pseudovirus resulted in
damage to the lungs and arteries
of an animal model proving that the
spike protein alone was enough to cause
disease
tissue samples showed inflammation in
endothelial cells lining the pulmonary
artery walls
and then later in the same article they
say this is the first study to show that
the damage occurs when cells are exposed
to the spike protein
on its own
everyone has been paying attention knows
that every one of the vaccines that is
being deployed not just the mrna
vaccines but also the dna vaccines
uses the spike protein and if this
research holds again this is animal
model
i can't see the original research this
just came out
um it was in it isn't a peer-reviewed
journal but
you know all those caveats if this holds
uh this right here is reason to be
concerned about the
kinds of vaccines that we have right now
many of us
are hoping that there is a traditional
vaccine under development which i would
get in line for right away um but
the spike protein itself researchers at
the salk institute have found
now um is causing disease is partially
responsible for causing the disease
known as
covid um that is a bombshell
yeah it's an absolute bombshell and um
you know there are a lot of different
mechanisms that could be in play here
it could be the spike protein so i do
want to
eventually see that paper
but uh you know it could be that the
spike protein
is triggering the immune system to do
this damage which would explain you know
it's interesting that the list of
symptoms that they found in their
model animal um is
very similar to some of the worst
symptoms of covid and some of the most
deadly
and but you know what people need to
understand is that the the whole trick
the reason that this vaccine which is a
marvelous technological or these
vaccines which are a marvelous
technological achievement to have gotten
them so quickly
the way they work is they take the
message for spike protein they isolate
it from everything else and they get a
mechanism to deliver it to the cell and
then your cell
produces spike protein so basically we
have a
synthetic virus-like entity a
nanoparticle
covered piece of mrna that triggers you
to produce spike protein and now
we know that at least in a model
organism and that model organism is sure
to be a mammal
um yeah i'm looking for it it is a
mammal you keep talking yeah figure out
what it is
it is doing the damage of kovid all on
its own so you know that's a very
surprising result
what one wants to compare it to is what
we've been saying from the beginning
which is we hope these vaccines
work really really well but you are
walking into a
a complex system and imagining that
it's a simple system and the range of
things that could go wrong here
is huge so um
i i hope that you know frankly i hope
that research is wrong that's a very
devastating
result if it's true very much so um
yeah i i'm not finding i saw it when i
was looking through what i could find
earlier
i can't figure out what the uh animal
model they used was but it was a mammal
it was it was a rodent of some sort i
think
probably gonna be a mouse but um i don't
remember
um all right so
let's just say um
the individual versus
collective analysis is important and the
question is
whether we are in a place where society
can
force us to behave in what it claims is
the collective interest which in this
case it may not be
and i would point out for those who have
not looked at
my podcast with uh with gear vandonbush
the his argument is that this is
actually going to make the pandemic
worse now again i didn't know then and i
still don't know
whether he's right i will say given that
something more than a third of
the u.s population has been vaccinated
and yet we are seeing
uh an increase in cases one has to
wonder what's going on we're also seeing
an increase in variance but
you know the data is noisy and um i
think it's going to take time to figure
out but
i also want to start seeing the data on
especially in the places
in the world and in the country where
cases are increasing
what the ratio you know if if there are
as few breakthrough cases
for vaccinated people as we are being
told
or if um for instance new variants
um you know people who are vaccinated
are at risk for new variants and that
they are a surprising
percentage of the people who are getting
sick i don't know if that's the case but
i have not seen the analysis and i
haven't been able to find it
right um so what i've seen is i've seen
uh garrett demonized and portrayed as
having a financial conflict of interest
i should say i contacted him to
ask him about that he does not
apparently have a financial conflict of
interest there is an old patent which
uh did not go through um and so is long
since dormant
but he appears to be acting out of his
belief and he also sent me i should say
a long list of predictions if his model
is correct he would expect to see
these things you know behaving exactly
as a scientist who would behave in such
circumstances and so i guess to
my guess is he also hopes he's wrong he
does in fact he says that multiple times
he doesn't want to be right because of
us who are being cautious and skeptical
here
of these amazing new miracle cures
hope we're wrong to be skeptical not not
you know not that it's an error to be
skeptical but hope that the skepticism
yes hope that our fears worn out that
our fears are not warranted
and um it's a very uncomfortable
position to be and it's one
you know frankly the good scientists
have to learn
nobody is born wanting to be wrong
right that is not a normal state but um
but anyway it's it's one you learn i
will say i
i do have the sense that we are watching
i i haven't come up with a good name for
it yet but effectively
um there's a thing the good people
game right and the good people game is
like a massive
online game like it's literally a
massive
online multiplayer game and the idea
you know there's a version on the left
and there's a version on the right and
at the moment we are seeing the version
uh on the left which holds so many
properties
that you know it effectively owns the
whole territory
but the idea is that the good people
game
that good people can be recognized by
certain things that you can just
simply spot them you know that good
people will
get their vaccine and they will boast
about their vaccine
status that they will wear masks
whenever they can be
observed they do not question
covet origins they treat discussion of
the financial incentives
of vaccine producers as forbidden
and they believe that science is
reducible to a list of clear answers
which you just simply
follow they punish anyone who discusses
vaccine
safety in anything other than glowing
terms
and they place uh greater good signals
above the well-being of their own
children and family and frankly i'm sick
of it right
i feel like the good people the ones who
actually uh care
about science are all permanently in a
state
of trying to sort through the nuances of
these things
and what the the good people game
effectively does is it rules out the
very territory that we
have to go to right you have to be able
to say
hey joe rogan you might be right about a
21 year old who's healthy
you're not right about covid not being a
dangerous disease
right um you have to be able to say that
and to the extent that the idea is oh no
no
you've expressed nuance you're not one
of the good people you're one of the bad
people
then of course we're going to end with a
disaster of one kind or another whether
it's of the sort that uh garrett
vandenbush is predicting
or it's as a result of uh
unforeseeable autoimmune disorders that
arise out of these vaccines or who knows
what it's going to be
but in effect we have to have a much
more open conversation which isn't going
to be
comfortable for people but it's the only
way to get to a decent outcome
that's right and you know it changes
this week the good people have stars on
their bellies or are they the ones
without
it it goes back and forth of course and
um
it's not about actually understanding
what's what's true
and what's best for us it's about
signaling and i think unfortunately
um what follows from that is
good people get the vaccine without
questioning it even in their heart of
hearts
and a vaccine passport is a way to
actually signal that
and so part of the reason i think that
people so many people
on the left who would be norm under
normal circumstances pretty
anti-authoritarian
are saying well of course we should have
this like well so that's
that's your public signal to the world
that you did the good people thing
and there are a lot of us who were
saying actually
i assume that most people are going to
get vaccinated but
that thing i don't want the government
having that thing
in an app and on my phone and having the
information and
and and and and all of this
um so boy there's just there's so much
that follows
that falls downstream from what you just
said about the good people
and i would say i guess i think maybe we
won't
talk about we're going to spend some
time on relative risk reduction versus
absolute risk reduction maybe we'll
come back to that um it seems like we
sort of moved on from that but
i will say i think it's actually could i
persuade you to go there
because it's well let's go this other
place first okay um
i feel like we've become a society of um
of active like enforcement officers for
drug pushing
but only some drugs and this is this
this is part of it that's really driving
me crazy right like
you know you you must you must have
these one of these new vaccines despite
the fact that there literally cannot be
long-term
safety data for them um you must
uh agree that puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones for
children and young adults are safe or
else you know you're not a good person
you're not one of us
but um we can't we can't talk about
ivermectin
right can we we can't talk about
ivermectin it's not vetted even though
it's been around for decades and has a
great safety track record
so here's um here's
again washington post on april 18th
of this year's i just show it briefly um
a article with the headline supporters
tout anti-parasite drug as cobit 19
treatment
but skeptics call it the new
hydroxychloroquine
an nih trial may subtle debate over
ivermectin officials warn people not to
take animal formulation of the drug wait
i think they misspelled trump
well so that's the thing get this i mean
you're gonna love this here's a quote
from the end of this article
again dated april 8 2021 it's like the
new hydroxychloroquine said angela
rasmussen
a virologist at georgetown university's
center for global health science and
security
referring to the malaria drug pushed by
president donald trump that proved
ineffective against coven 19.
quote it would be great if ivermectin
did work it's been around for years and
is cheap
but to my knowledge there is no data
that suggests it's good for covet 19.
rasmussen concluded
wow so logical fallacies are now being
employed like against drugs
not even against arguments now i don't
even know which one this is it's like
it's guilty like a chemical category
like it's
there's there's like two steps of guilt
by association one of which isn't even a
person
right but you all you have to do is like
vaguely gesture in the direction of
trump and like well no
you don't want to get anywhere near that
do you so we're supposed to
uh we're supposed to accept cross-sex
hormones for 16 year olds
and vaccines that are brand new on the
market as 100
safe when you're crazy if you say
they're not and not
not consider a drug that's literally
been on the market for decades
and has years of efficacy data not for
coveted 19 because zekovo 19 is very
very new
but the idea that it is harmful is very
very very slim so i will just say
you have pointed out on a previous
podcast
the perverse financial incentive and the
massive benefit potentially to
pharmaceutical companies of
pushing the idea that it is morally
right to
uh not only allow but basically insist
on
puberty blockers uh for kids who express
any any
sort of trans tendencies or arguably
trans tendencies
and here we have uh you know
pharmaceutical companies with an obvious
perverse incentive
you know partially their research is
publicly financed
but they benefit massively from a
program that we all
have to participate in or we can't
travel this is becoming absurd
right so my sense is look if you want me
to accept the idea of a vaccine passport
i'm all ears
but i'm not doing it if the people
pushing it
are financially incentivized to ignore
hazards that are obvious
right those hazards are there right how
bad are they
we don't know as you and i have been
saying four months
um but we're not it's possible that no
one knows
but we are not allowed to know we you're
not allowed to know and
um i'm really hoping we get back to that
relative versus absolute uh
risk paper which uh i only
i read through it once but i was pretty
stunned by it
okay um let's let's just do it briefly
so um
we got these concepts of absolute risk
and relative risk
absolute risk is um the total risk of a
given thing occurring after all the risk
factors and confounding variables are
summed up
for example you could sum up your
lifetime risk of getting coveted based
on the incidence and prevalence of your
demographic
relative risk is different and for these
vaccines
we are we are hearing about relative
risk reduction rather than absolute risk
reduction relative risk is different
relative risk
is the risk of a given thing in
comparison to something else for example
your risk of developing
uh covet if you get vaccinated compared
to if you don't get vaccinated
so um when
let's see there's just a lot of places
we could go here um okay how about this
so there's a paper out um you can show
my screen i think zach let me get it
bigger here
um outcome reporting bias in cobit 19
mrna vaccine clinical trials by getting
ronald guy named ronald brown
came out february of this year he has
this graphic at the top of page three
which is um just that the numbers are
made up right but this is just his
visual
and again i'll try to describe it for
those of you just listening
of the difference between relative risk
and absolute risk
um the idea is um you've got a
population of people who have taken the
vaccine
and in his hypothetical one person who
took the vaccine out of a hundred ended
up with the disease
and in his hypothetical of the hundred
piece people who took the placebo
two people out of the hundred got the
disease um so with those numbers with
those
made-up numbers the absolute risk
reduction
would be the difference between those
two numbers in both cases
basically 0.02 minus 0.01 um
oh um actually he doesn't he doesn't
this isn't as clear as i thought it was
um
the absolute risk reduction is
we really need to walk through this more
in depth um in the place where we were
trying to do it uh brett can you help me
out here
i can't even see it so what we
what we have is with regard to absolute
risk reduction
yeah um
boy i just i i'm just getting myself
confused here yeah
um the absolute risk reduction is uh
for his numbers one percent
uh whereas the because that's out of the
the difference is
two minus one people who got it out of a
population
of of a hundred and the relative risk
reduction
is uh one person got it from the
vaccinated group versus two people got
it from the
unvaccinated placebo group so that's one
in two so
50 relative risk reduction and
um this paper so that was a terrible
explanation i'm sorry about that
but this paper he then goes through the
math and i did not have time to check
all of his math here
but he arrives at these numbers here
with regard to what he's done
before i show this what he has done is
he has taken the numbers available from
the clinical trials for both pfizer and
moderna vaccines
and and said okay well pfizer reports
uh 95.1 relative risk
reduction from using the pfizer vaccine
but the absolute risk reduction given
the numbers is
0.7 percent and the modern
vaccine modena reports in 94.1
relative risk reduction but uh
calculating the absolute risk reduction
from their own clinical trial data you
get a 1.1
absolute risk reduction so zach can i
have my screen back i think if i could
see my notes i might be able to do a
better job here
um and
so there are two up shots that i thought
were very important here
one is apparently both numbers are
required to be
reported but somehow there's an
oversight here and we're only getting
the more dramatic number which supports
the application of the vaccine but more
importantly and you know and again i'm
not
i'm not sure i object to one
number only being reported because most
most people do not
are not paying attention anyway etc but
but i mean i want more transparency
around words like effective we are being
told
95 effective right and if we were told
95
0.7 percent effective depending on
whether or not you're looking at
relative risk or absolute risk reduction
then people are going to start to go
wait what and it's that wait
what moment that our public health
officials and our government don't want
us doing
our publications but without more
information we need to be allowed to do
that right
our public health officials and
pharmaceutical companies
with a perverse incentive right so my
when i say that they're required to i
mean in the filings for these things
they're required to report them and so
this paper i read as
alarmed that this number that should be
available to those who want to dig and
find it is not easily available
and the other thing though the really
important thing
is that if you are trying to calculate
whether or not
to take an unknown risk of a long-term
harm
you know there's some short-term risk
there's some people have died it's not a
large number but some people have died
we've had a blood clots i've had people
report to me very severe
local reactions near injection sites but
if you're trying to decide whether or
not to accept
those risks what are you going to
compare it to
the point is which of those numbers is
actually a more reliable guide to the
value because what you're really trying
to do
is compare a value of the vaccine to a
risk
that comes with the vaccine and um so
the value to you as an
individual is much lower than it would
seem but the value to the population
is a better match for the relative risk
reduction number which is what we are
seeing
and i i will say so i will also post
both that paper
but also this and zach you can just show
this this blog post
um called the blog is called statistical
modeling causal inference and social
science
and this particular post from the 12th
of april this year um relative versus
absolute risk reduction 500 doctors want
to know
this guy writes i think a fairly
compelling
argument for why yes we absolutely do
need to
to be to be made aware of absolute risk
reduction but i don't think that
this changes the analysis um and he
actually does a much better job of
describing the distinction between the
two than than i did so
um i think we got there but i mean i
what
what what i want is for everyone who is
interested to have access both that
paper
um that paper that i was showing images
from and this blog post
um that is saying yeah here's what the
paper says and there's nothing new here
and um the argument for the distinction
between absolute risk reduction
and relative risk reduction is something
you could learn on wikipedia that's fine
nothing shameful about repeating stuff
that is sort of common knowledge for
statisticians
but i don't i the author here doesn't
think that it changes
the the overall
decisions that people should be making
that's fine
as long as we're informed right we are
not properly informed we are not
properly informed and we are also in a
position
where the pharmaceutical industry
has corrupted government
it is teamed up with tech platforms
and everyone has decided for us that the
risks that
you and i know one has to be worried
about because they are not
so they are not negligible that those
risks are
uh overblown and that only bad people
talk about them
you know it happens that they don't seem
you know they don't seem to like
drugs that they don't stand to profit a
great deal from and so the point is oh
those drugs are not promising
right and so how many of these things
would have to go in this direction where
you know uh okay bill gates is an
authority on vaccines he really is
but he's also lying to us about the
capacity to produce more of them
if the patent structure was altered for
the purpose of the pandemic
okay that's interesting fauci
you know who has demonstrated a
willingness to lie to us
about masks and has also demonstrated
rotten judgment
with respect to gain of function
research is now telling us and in the
clip i i didn't show you the fouchy clip
but he talks about the fact that we're
going to need to vaccinate children well
there are reasons you wouldn't want to
even if this vaccine thing
was safe enough for us adults
there are multiple reasons why as the
risk of serious covet drops off with
kids you might want to exclude them
one they're still going through
development you could be impacting their
development in a way
that wouldn't put us adults at risk but
will put them at risk too
they're going to live longer that means
the downstream consequences of something
we don't know about these vaccines
is that much greater three the value to
them
is much lower if they're not going to
get particularly sick from kovid
and so you know the relative degree to
which
that risk uh is not warranted in their
case
is substantial so they're telling us a
conclusion
to the extent that we can check their
conclusion it doesn't add up
to the extent we can check their
perverse incentives they're all over the
place
so you know at what point do we get to
ask the question
you know yes we have a real you know
pandemic it's a medical phenomenon
and it has medical implications and yes
we can't be completely free to choose
for ourselves
whether to wear masks in a place where
the disease can be transmitted or
whether to get a vaccine if it's
actually
safe enough but in light of all of the
um the shenanigans that have been
deployed
over these very questions at what point
are we entitled to protect ourselves
from bad
information coming from every channel
all right i will get off my soapbox at
that point
so we're at over an hour already um
and you want to talk about um portland
maybe we can do that briefly yeah
a little bit on race and a lot on nature
okay
so i feel an obligation for us to talk
about portland um
the reason we talked a bit about mayor
wheeler having done something unusual
last time which is he
stood up and said that the anarchists
who are
breaking the windows of businesses and
setting fires and all have to be
in his words unmasked and arrested um
the anarchists came back this week and i
don't know the anarchists
but someone among the anarchists a
self-declared
member of antifa put out a video
in the style of anonymous
but this was actually quite different
than any anonymous video i've seen
before
zach do you want to uh show it
yeah hello we come to you as a small
collective from within the anarchist and
not speak for the whole as each
individual may carry
different ideologies and beliefs about
how things
could should or will be accomplished we
hope with this message to simply convey
a few points that are commonly agreed
upon within this community
the mayor of this city is undeserving of
his position
he has made it abundantly clear that
windows to him
are more important than human life but
we are not just challenging the idea
of having ted as a mayor we are
challenging
the idea of having mayors at all we want
abolition abolition is absolutely
peaceful marches
speeches and voting where enough to
bring about that goal then we would have
already been there
window smashing and riots are a
necessary
escalation when those in power have
proven that they are
unwilling to listen and have made the
choice to ignore you we are moving with
a sense of urgency
because not only is the system
destroying us it's destroying the very
planet that we live on
this movement encompasses the liberation
of all those oppressed by the system
whether it be black
indigenous hispanic etc nobody owns this
movement
and wants who are trying to claim
ownership of this movement just leads to
more division which is counterproductive
to all of our goals we are on the same
side though
and the more time we spend fighting each
other the less energy we have to fight
the true enemy
so let's start local with our own city's
failed leadership
ted we are asking for the last time that
you resign
if you ignore this message outright the
destruction to your precious way of life
is going to escalate
blood is already on your hands ted but
next time
it may just be your own
okay so what you've just seen is a video
in which ted wheeler is
threatened at the end um and doxxed
the video that we showed had his address
uh
blurred out but but anyway this is quite
serious stuff
to have anarchists threatening your
mayor and police chief and i'm very much
hoping that
that uh mayor wheeler will um stand his
ground
and i think that this is evidence that
he needs to actually increase
uh his commitment even beyond because
obviously this is a response to his
saying that they need to be unmasked and
arrested
and if they're going to up the ante by
threatening public officials then
obviously
um capitulation would be an insane thing
to do and
um you know anyway i hope he has the
courage to do what must be done
but the other thing is this has not been
widely reported
yeah and that i find absolutely stunning
there was a death threat made by a bunch
of anonymous thugs against a
sitting mayor of
a major american city and they say if i
remember correctly
we are not just challenging the idea of
having ted wheeler as mayor we are
challenging the idea of having mayors at
all we want abolition
they just keep on saying it you know
they they're really not pretending
um and no this isn't the same you know
this this isn't
the thousands of people who were showing
up for the daytime protests
but this is some of the same people who
stuck around night after night and
you know the destruction downtown has is
experiencing a
renaissance and uh and you know and here
we go and into the middle of this into
the middle of this fray so
you um reported on
wheelers standing up to them
saying that they need to be unmasked and
arrested last week
and in response uh one of our city
councilmen
has chided him so here we have from
willamette week which is our
local free news weekly heartisty joann
hardistee is the council person in
question hardesty says wheeler must hold
police accountable
if he wants an end to destructive
marches
in chiding wheeler hardesty waded into
an ongoing civic debate about portland
policing
and the nighttime protests by a group of
roughly 100 leftists
so i will say that that you know that
sub-headline in particular is just
full of um i would say
beyond imprecise but inaccurate language
as well
nighttime protests um ongoing civic
debate
um she chiding him um and i used that
word when i was introducing this but
here we go just the first paragraph
portland city commissioner joanne
hardisty issued a measured rebuke
that's more accurate wednesday to mayor
ted wheeler's call for a crackdown on
black block marchers who smash windows
saying the city shouldn't expect peace
until it disciplines police officers who
thrashed protesters last summer
this is a city a sitting city
commissioner who says the city
in which she has a seat should not
expect peace
until police officers who thrashed
protesters last summer are disciplined
now
i am unaware of thrashing
that happened and there will be plenty
of people who say oh here's a video here
like
you know what we covered this in more
detail than i care to
um but i am i am not compelled
that the portland police or the um
the feds when they were allowed to be
here um
did thrashing here in portland
i am not compelled yeah no and of course
everything here is turned on its head
cause and effect wise this was going on
long before
blm protests long before george floyd
yes
um you know and i think again this week
uh
the anarchists wait wait what was going
on long before george
the anarchist in the pacific northwest
uh
right but but this wasn't no no this is
not going on this is new but my point is
the idea
that the precipitating event is the
thrashing of the anarchists by
police is absurd especially in the
larger context and
you can see this in the fact that when
we arrived in portland
they were already periodically taking
over intersections
and what would the term be harassing
drivers threatening them it happened
again this week
so the point is this is the same old
same old being portrayed in a context
that generates sympathy on some fronts
but you know the smart people aren't
buying it
yeah okay um i seem to have spent
more time than i usually do on the
washington post this week because i have
another washington post article
just published right today
why isn't it not clicking through for me
there we go okay zach again just show my
screen for me to read the headline
opinion this is an op-ed published today
in in wapo
kamala harris has to walk a tightrope on
race this time
she slipped so that got my attention
washington post thinks kamala harris
slipped on race
um paragraph two reads
it all started wednesday night with the
words of another black political figure
while delivering the gop response to
president biden's address to congress
south carolina senator tim scott said
flatly that quote america is not a
racist country
the predictable backlash sent scott
rushing to fox news to whine
that black people on the radical left
are being mean to him because of the
color his skin
skipper had one paragraph paragraph 4 in
the same op-ed
but republican denial is a familiar
story the plot twist came when harris
seconded scott
no i don't think america is a racist
country she said on good morning america
the next day
our vice president said she doesn't
think this is a racist country
you know what uh michael kinsley defines
a gaffe as no when a politician tells
the truth
well i don't i actually i don't know if
harris thinks it was a gaff i said off
script because that was my imagining
because certainly that is not the
that is not the rhetoric that we heard
from her during the campaign
at all but that is like that is
one of the few hopeful notes that i find
this week
of like she said what now on national
television
that that strikes me as potentially very
good news
well i mean you just don't like good
news
there's a there's an album for people
like me is there yeah
i think the title is uh good news for
people who
like bad news or something like that
it's a modest mouse anyway um
the the problem here is that the person
in question is cynical
and yes maybe she's come around to
speaking the truth you know it's not
that there's not racism in the country
but it's not a racist country
um and you know we do better over time
um but i don't know recently yeah well
all right
um but i i'm not sure how to feel
about kamala harris saying
true things all of a sudden it's like
well what have you just put us through
what kind of danger have you just put us
in by pretending otherwise and you know
i do wonder if at some level i mean you
saw
james carville this week
said effectively wokeness
is a problem and everybody knows it
right so behind the scenes there's some
sort of discussion going on and this
could be
part of a planned change in posture
which
would be positive but for the fact that
you know as we said during the election
you basically have
uh the blue team cynically uh playing
ftse with
um with wokeness and they won't be able
to control it
though they think they can so maybe this
is even that next phase
okay um actually in in conjunction with
the
the carville uh quote or
whatever um that does
that does dampen my enthusiasm a little
bit it uh
yeah i can always rely on you for a good
cynical take oh well thank you
very kind of you darling um so
sort of related maybe ish the ap the
associated press
uh reports and you can show my screen
here zach um i don't know why we're just
hearing about this now this is from july
20th 2020 but i just ran into it this
week and i saw some other people
were too ap says it will capitalize
black
but not white after changing its usage
rules last month to capitalize the word
black when used in the context of race
and culture the associated press on
monday said it would not do the same for
white
the ap said white people in general have
much less shared history and culture
and don't have the experience of being
discriminated against because of skin
color
so okay don't have the experience of
being discriminated against because of
skin color
true so irrelevant to the question of
capitalization
obviously um the first part of the
sentence white people in general have
much less shared history and culture
i i can't even read that sentence
without
i don't know a combination of like
laughing and rolling my eyes and wanting
to
slit my wrists or something like my god
did these people not understand
basic basic truths about who we are and
where we came from
and oh by the way
like europe and europeans created a
culture that actually has meaning
and yes it's a lot of cultures but for
god's sake so i was thinking that we
would do like a diversion into
some evolutionary concepts like
monophyletic and paraphilia and
polyphily i think this is not the place
maybe we'll save that for
another time but the fact is we were all
originally black
we were all originally africans so
blackness
is in systematics speak this like
parapheletic group
like some of us have have changed and we
don't look black anymore but we all
originally are african i've changed
because
the sun comes through the atmosphere at
a steeper angle therefore there's less
uv
radiation where our immediate ancestors
came from it's astronomical and
implications and
so mundane yeah right like astronomical
and mundane
i think in some sense you know you've
missed the scariest part of this story
okay okay they're not gonna capitalize
white
okay in order not to capitalize white
they are going to have to keep white at
the back of the sentence because if it
came at the front of the sentence
grammatical rules would force them to do
it
no no wow
your disdain is is radiant
just just now okay yeah i tried
you did i did you did okay oh
boy it's 151 um let's talk about nature
yes i was hoping that we would spend the
entire time today talking about nature
and we're not going to you know
you're not talking about the british
journal you're talking about nature
herself
no i don't i don't want to talk about
any more scientific publication oh
actually i do have one scientific
publication
of course um so
yeah actually let's finish with the
with the pictures okay sure um because
that's sort of the most dramatic we got
this dramatic thing that we saw this
week
um but we also saw a few other really
cool things this week and first i want
to talk about the thing that we didn't
get to but what's happening right now is
just finishing it happens every year
which is the shorebird migration um that
many many species of birds
who breed who have have summer breeding
grounds in alaska and canada
and spend the winter in the south of the
southern us or mexico or farther south
um they their southward migration in the
fall
is much more dispersed in time there is
nothing there fleeing
exactly except for an encroaching winter
which comes somewhat slowly
whereas um seasonal breeders being what
they are you know humans aren't seasonal
breeders but almost all organisms are
interestingly actually among the um you
know the sort of closer to us in
primates we get the less seasonal our
breeding gets and that's also an
interesting
to me conversation to be had um but all
these shorebird species
have a you know limited period of time
during which they can
they can find mates and rate and
lay eggs and raise broods and they can
fledge before they have to escape again
to the
to the south and they have to meet
partners and so the timing of landing on
breeding grounds in the north is really
quite tight and that means that whereas
the southward migration
every year is dispersed and if you go to
any of the places where the birds tend
to come through in the fall you'll see
some
but in for a few weeks every spring
at a few spots in north america and i'm
sure this is true in
um in europe europe and africa for
instance as well and other places but
i'm much less familiar with that
you can reliably see uh thousands tens
of thousands
hundreds of thousands even of birds if
you go at the right time
uh so there are in fact five distinct
spots
in um in north america where birds
reliably come through
and actually have this this to read from
this for people who
like birds i recommend this the birders
handbook a field guide to the natural
history of north american birds
the essential companion to your
identification guide
and we've got in here marked with a book
dart
somewhere of course of course um
here we go in north america five such
sites support more than a million
shorebirds annually now this is from
1988 these numbers may have declined
some since then
um in north america five such sites
support more than a million shorebirds
annually
alaska's copper river delta washington's
grays harbor
eastern canada's bay of fundy kansas's
cheyenne bottoms
and the beaches of delaware bay in new
jersey and delaware
more than 80 percent of the entire north
american population of some species may
join ranks at any of these key locations
virtually all western sandpipers and
dunlands use the copper river site
and then he says the series of critical
stopover sites is typified by delaware
bay
the arrival and departure of five
hundred thousand to one million
five hundred thousand shorebirds within
a span of three to four weeks
is synchronized with the annual breeding
cycle of the bay's enormous population
of horseshoe crabs
for it is the eggs of the crabs that
supply the energy required by the birds
to complete their spring journey to the
arctic
each evening after day-long feasting on
crab eggs the birds move east to roost
and tidal marshes
and on the outer beaches of the atlantic
coast coastal and wetland development
have forced the birds into ever smaller
foraging and roosting sites as the
number of suitable areas has dwindled
on high tide nights more than a hundred
thousand shorebirds may be packed into a
few hundred yards of beach
so i've never been there um and i you
surprised me this week when you told me
that you actually hadn't been out to
crazy i have not been
but i used to last year around this time
i guess actually in yeah this this month
last year on this podcast
i talked some about steve herman who
died last year who was one of the almost
founding members
of um of evergreen an excellent
ornithologist a man that i was actually
hired to replace even though i'm not an
ornithologist
and he introduced me to the grays harbor
shorebird festival it's called
and the migration there and indeed later
started
the amazing field station down in sonora
on the sea of cortez called navapatia
and in navapatia which is one of the
places that a lot of these birds
overwinter you can see them
you can see these birds in january
february and so this again for people
who care about birds
the shorebird guide um is is is terrific
and i'm not going to read from it but
um we didn't get out there this week as
i was hoping to
and now the birds are are mostly on
their way north
um we were hoping to impart a flat tire
which never happens anymore but a flat
tire got us
um got us
uh and i wanna just show if i can
find safari why is my computer doing
this um
oh my goodness um okay i can't show it
because
my computer's not playing nice with me
at all
um there is um
maybe after we talk a little bit i'll
figure out a way to show it um
the there is much to be said about why
migrate
and i found i used to do a whole
section on migration when i spent a
whole year teaching vertebrate evolution
and
um you know talking about you know how
different species migrate
how far they might go why what what
their what they're going towards what
they're cycling around you know what
what all are the factors that drive how
efficient their migrations are when they
migrate how many they migrate with all
of this
and so this that that i would love to
come back to
but maybe that is for now all we'll say
about the
amazing shorebirds sure we could come
back to it um you
probably don't recall it's been so many
years now but uh
there was a section in my dissertation
about why birds
migrate that had everything to do with
trade-offs
it's going to have been relative to the
latitude latitudinal diversity gradient
well yeah the same logic that explains
why the latitudinal diversity gradient
is what it is also explains why things
would participate in multiple
latitudes well that yeah so i don't
think you ever heard
um really because we weren't teaching
the same stuff
when i went into migration in depth it
would be we could
we could riff live on migration totally
and if we disagree we could we could
battle it out
we could microsome machetes oh yeah or
migrate that's true too
yeah um okay so uh we didn't i didn't
get to see the shorebirds this year
um i mean that there are some and
actually um they're they're still flying
over and they still are being funneled
to these these sites and at different
times actually it just happens to be
grace harbor which is
um close to us here um is the spot that
i know best
um but we did one night last week
um go out just into our own landscape
and it was
um close to or just after the full moon
the full moon was on the 26th i know
that because it was my birthday
and we never saw it because of the the
cloud cover and we were i don't know
somehow we were out and then and then we
were in just before the full moon showed
itself
um but we went out either that night or
the next night
um after midnight um you had been out
maybe with maddie and you said
come on out you're going to want to see
this and we must have found
two dozen salamanders it was a lot a lot
of salamanders and they're in these
little tiny
tubes little tiny dirt tubes that
they've dug into the earth and we've got
we live on pretty steeply sloped forest
here
and so they basically built them into
these dirt walls excavated them
um i'm pretty sure they're western
red-backed salamanders plethodon
vehiculum
vehiculum vehicular what are they
driving it i don't know
um so plethodont as you will know
is the type genus for plethodona day and
that is a family
it's a giant family of salamanders all
of which are lungless
so that you know that again something i
could go on about for a while but um
it it raises the question of course how
they're breathing and mostly not
entirely but most of their breathing
through their skin because they
literally have no lungs they don't have
gills
um so anyway we have many many many of
these guys in our landscape right around
here and during the daytime you cannot
find them yeah
you cannot find them at all um and then
earlier in the week we went on on on my
birthday
you and me and toby our younger son our
producer and older son zack
um was at school but the three of us
went out to the columbia river gorge
and the columbia river gorge for those
of you not in the pacific northwest or
especially if you are and you've never
been
is an extraordinary glorious place
and the first time i went there i was
actually taken
by a then emeritus professor from the
university of
oregon bob storm
who met me and my um program my
evergreen program there and showed us
some remarkable sites and we went
looking for
tailed frogs and we found tadpoles but
not the frogs um
at multnomah falls and we also went um
to a place that i'm not going to name
because it just it's since been closed
um but where you could climb up this
scree field this like this
steep scree field and end up at the base
of a natural arch
and underneath the rocks that you were
standing on
if you're there at the right time of
year which we were right time if you're
if you're someone like me wrong time of
year if you're like a lot of people
um you could hear the fact that you were
actually standing on what doc's storm
had um had demonstrated was in fact the
largest rattlesnake den
in the pacific northwest and they were
just um
they were just sort of waking up and you
could hear them just rattling under
there
and we i was hoping
i was hoping for my birthday to find
some rattlesnakes that was that was what
i was hoping for
so um we start off on our on our hike
yumi and toby and there's a rock in the
middle of a paved path the paved path
quickly gives way to
actual actual trail but in a rock in the
middle of a paved path we find the one
and only rattlesnake that we will see
the entire time
and it's uh as a small collective but
yeah that was it that's it yeah it
okay um that rattlesnake will be right
back yeah yeah
um he's so cute um so it was a baby
and he didn't have a rattle he had just
the button
just a button um but definitely
rattlesnake
and um definitely acted like a
rattlesnake when uh
when i tried to move him to a safer spot
that wasn't in a rock right in the
middle of the path and
um i did not have i did not have a snake
stick with me which is a long metal rod
with a
with a kind of a hook on the end that
you can use to pin or hook snakes
um so um using found sticks didn't seem
all that safe and i tried a little bit
and then yeah they were too short um so
anyway we saw that
which pleased me and we'd never we
didn't see any more um it was a
beautiful day out there perfect for
snakes to be out and then
and then maybe 20 feet later down the
trail
we hold on take that off please
um there's an osprey that's coming up
over the river so the
the columbia is is a fair bit down to
the to the right
um but there are a lot of birds floating
on the thermals and playing around with
the wind we're right near hood river
which is um like the
mecca for kiteboarding and yeah exactly
it's super windy
um and this osprey is sort of you know
floating
um and up behind it comes what looks at
first like another osprey but it turns
out to be
a raven with a gopher snake and it's i
don't even remember was it its beak or
its
um feet and it comes like brighter i
mean i didn't let it come right over my
head because as much as i like snakes i
didn't feel like having it
just dropped on me um pretty low and
then lands on this basalt ledge
right like maybe 12 feet above us and
then so zach you can show this picture
now
um the the raven then proceeds to
um pin the snake with his feet and just
eviscerate it just pulled out the
stomach use and
um and you know you could see it hanging
out of
both its intestines both sides of the
raven's beak
another raven came in kind of wanted a
piece of the action
first raven flies off deals with raven
two
comes back picks up the carcass of the
snake
and flies off totally extraordinary it
was amazing
amazing really really nice bird hard to
photograph
but oh that's that's beautiful
so um i don't know from that picture if
anyone's gonna be able to tell for sure
if it's a
raven or a crow i feel like i got a good
enough look yeah i was certain at the
time and then i looked at the photos and
something about the angle made the bill
look thinner than i had thought but i'm
pretty sure it was a raven
and we also i mean we saw what seemed to
us to be three or four of the ravens on
our walk and we never saw any crows
yeah that's right um anything else you
want to say about
no it was uh it was amazing and uh it
reminds me
you know we are frequently asked in
light of all of the crazy things that
are famous about
portland now um why we live here and one
of them is that we are just surrounded
by
fascinating uh things and the columbia
river gorge has an amazing
little-known story of its creation
and the uh the wildlife uh
is spectacular and we're not far from
mount hood and in fact
uh this uh raven incident happened
uh at hood river where a river descends
from the
the um the hills the foothills of uh
of mount hood and into the columbia
river gorge it's a tributary so anyway
it's a it's a lovely spot
and uh well we were actually we were on
the washington side actually yes
um so um i don't know what i don't
remember what river would be descending
into the columbia from there but wood
river will be descending the little
white salmon
near there yeah yeah um
and maybe we have a thumbnail for this
week
well i was sort of thinking it would be
either the rattlesnake or the
raven or i took there were also these
odd uh
cute curbitacious um a little squash
family plants i got some nice pictures
of the
things that coil around but i didn't i
didn't get one ready in time for the
stream
so maybe we'll surprise people with it
or we'll go with one of the others yeah
i don't know we didn't look it up but
clearly
uh cucurbit um squash which is one of
the
um one of the three sisters of some
native american culinary traditions
where you combine
corn beans and squash i think probably
not this far north
right because i don't think corn was
this far north ever
but combining corn beans and squash
provided all the nutrients you needed um
all the protein um you know all of all
the essential amino acids
i believe without any animal protein um
so finding wild
wild squash out there was pretty kind of
cool i mean actually there were some of
them beginning to fruit
oh absolutely yeah yeah um anything else
um i don't think so i think we've we've
gotten there
all right so um as is
usual we will take a 15-minute break and
be back with the live q a answering
questions that you've asked this hour
and the answer and
ask next hour for those of you just
listening
we will be back in a week on may 8th
same time
same place and please consider joining
either of our
patreons at mine we will do
a once monthly two-hour private q a
on the last sunday of the month and
brett has conversations
through our conversations at his as well
coming up tomorrow morning sunday
may 2nd and next saturday
send any questions you have to
darkhorse.moderator gmail.com
and maybe that's it for now yeah
like subscribe comment
circulate clips achieve greatness all
those things
be good to the people you love and eat
good food and get outside
get outside all right be well everyone
you